welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marietta bolshevik an assistant
professor of Slavic languages and
literatures at Yale she is focused on
20th and 21st century Russian poetry
Russian and Balkan avant-gardes
diasporas and transnational culture
translation and adaptation acrost media
and the poetics and politics of the
Danube River she's the author of several
publications including Nabokov's cannon
from Onegin to odda
which is due out in 2016 today we talk
with her about her newest book project
titled avant-garde post radical poetics
after the Soviet Union welcome professor
thank you so much for having me let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it
okay so my new book project focuses on a
constellation or an archipelago if you
will of contemporary Russian poets
they're mostly based in st. Petersburg
and Moscow and they center around a
number of journals events series
programming series small publications
they work together and they have a
similar interest in that they are
engaged politically engaged poets which
is absolutely fascinating to me because
of course the context for politically
engaged poetry is very different in
today's Russia it's one thing to be an
explicitly leftist poet which these
poets that I study are in let's say an
academic American setting or working in
writing in France than it is to be
openly leftist in the year 2000 a mere
decade after the fall of the Soviet
Union so these are poets who are risking
something and their poetics engaged
radical politics or progressive politics
and experiments with a form this is what
interests me tremendously and my new
book project is an attempt to examine
this new cultural formation this loose
group or movement even if you will many
movement in the context of the oven
thinking of it as a new pulse of the
oven guard perhaps a continuation of a
paradoxical oven guard tradition okay
and what led you to start the book well
actually I had meant to work on
contemporary post-soviet poetry from
from many years ago in 2002 I had a
Fulbright to Russia I spent a year in
Moscow and was focusing on contemporary
at the time conceptualist post
conceptualist poetry mm-hmm I came back
from that research year and wrote a
master's thesis on conceptualist Russian
poetry but I let it go I felt somehow I
hadn't found my real protagonists yet
and I changed directions with my
research my dissertation and the first
book which she mentioned ended up being
on Nabokov on emigres and transnational
literature's which was something that I
felt I could do well then and in the
context of living and writing in New
York City which I was so it was a while
before I returned to contemporary poetry
as my project when I finished the the
first book mostly
I decided to return to Russia and have
been going back one or two times a year
for summers mostly and it began in 2012
I came to do research on contemporary
poetry and I walked straight into some
of the most exciting protests that I'd
ever encountered this had started in
2011 and was part of the now it's known
as the the long year 2012 immense
political protests all over the country
many in Moscow and Petersburg and I
somehow entered into this met many
people through these protests and I
asked around who were the poets who were
somehow central who were the poets who
were speaking the language who were the
the poets involved with protest culture
most actively I kept hearing the same
names over and over again names like
Keitel Mitzvah for example or Pavarotti
any of the journal Petersburg Journal
tenants niat and I thought okay I think
I found my protagonist and now I can
return to this project okay so because
it's such a press
- concept how did you do the research
for it
my research methods had to change
completely this is the first time that I
was working so actively on living
writers so it's a lot more risky a lot
less safe than working on the bulk of
and so did you get to speak to them
directly
absolutely so I I know and work with all
of these poets which means that my
methods are completely different it's
not archival research poking through
letters but it involves interviews for
the first time for me so I had to
completely retrain to figure out how to
be able to do that and how is that
process for you
a terrifying comment but it felt
challenging but extremely important
terrifying well because of course
there's simply the emotional risks you
can publish an interpretation of a poet
who can then completely disagree with
you or worse yet think that you're a
fool so there's that risk but also for
me I'm very sensitive about not wanting
to engage in something that seems like
intellectual or academic colonialism I
don't want to think about writing on
somehow static subjects but instead I
really try to think about it as a
collaboration with these poets and
writers and interviews really help with
that but also ways of gathering material
are completely different I in some cases
the materials gathered online because
many of these poets use live journal and
Facebook and Twitter and other forms of
disseminating non-traditional forms of
disseminating their work but in other
cases it involves being there being at
the performances where they read their
poems being in protest context to see
how let's say the reading or performance
of a poem galvanized as a crowd how it
how it works in our context interesting
so tell us a little bit about each of
the poet's that you include in the
project okay I'll start why I've
narrowed it down it has been
extraordinarily difficult to narrow it
down but to six poets and there's a
chapter each the way that the book is
currently working two of the poets have
actually been to Yale one kedo madea's
you've who has had an anthology of his
work published in English with n plus
one and ugly duckling press it's called
it's no good and
fantastic that anthology has also
received a great deal of acclaim and key
real madrid is getting really
international attention now he's
publishing also essays political essays
and cultural essays in places like the
new left review and he came to Yale two
years ago to give a reading and I think
that might have been the first
introduction to some of the students and
graduate students here to a this
wonderful figure and he's young and
dynamic and also sings and performs his
poems in a way that you absolutely
cannot be left indifferent when
listening and so that I think was the
the first introduction not only to him
and his poetics but also to the fact
that something extremely exciting and
new was happening in the poetry world in
Russia another poet who came here last
fall was Dimitri Goenka he's also an
academic a theorist and last fall he was
based in Iowa and the prestigious Iowa
Writers Workshop we managed to steal him
for day and a half and he came and gave
a reading and again we had his works in
the original and translation students
were able to meet him and ask him about
how he lives and works and also
questions like does he does he want to
stay in Russia
how does he conceive of that so these
are these are two that I've already been
here and actually this spring I'm
bringing three more in the context of a
conference that I'll mention a little
bit later one of them is a Georgian born
poet female poet Quixote choo Korolev
who writes these absolutely fabulous
poetic dramas that draw attention to and
imagine the voices of the the unheard
and unseen of of Moscow so the immigrant
workers the people who work at the the
cheap marketplaces in Enochs and her
work is absolutely marvelous she's also
an academic a theorist works on
anglo-american poetry which is in
literature which is very interesting
Alexander's kadam is also coming he is a
st. Petersburg institution in his own
right was associated with language
school poetry and somehow is always a
figure around whom
a constellation of other poets revolves
and then finally a younger poet PABA
scene youth who is one of the founders
of the journal Tanzania and who is
absolutely marvelous young impresario
full of energy and again whose I think
done more to create and push this
movement in Petersberg them than almost
anyone else so let me ask you our
especially for the poets that are living
in Russia now are they fearful of any
repercussions of their writings
abstractly speaking yes but this is not
something that that comes up in in
conversation not for their poetry so for
example poverty any of you goes by Pasha
was arrested during a reading of his
poetry it was for using obscenity in a
poem and he was he was let go
immediately now of course the context
could change but this has been it is not
quite the way that it is portrayed in
the media however some of these poets
are political activists who are at the
forefront of various various protest
various meetings and I think the more
actively politically engaged you are the
more you could be potentially at risk so
what are the subjects that these poets
are dealing with in terms of the protest
what are they protesting does it vary
from poet to poet it does also the style
the manner in which they express
themselves part of the reason that I'm
looking at six poets who are who are so
different from one another is because
I'm interested in this range Keadle
writes more I want to say deceptively
straightforward poetry where he might
talk about a march in the mayor's office
for example or protesters against
protesters standing and then being
attacked for trying to protest a forest
being brought down so that there's a
really kind of active openly political
aspect to his subjects he is very
inspired by the work of Charles Bukowski
and actually was a translator of
Bukowski's work into Russian so he
perhaps is on one extreme kate did you
call who i'm
writing is very they're very beautiful
very moving poetic dramas calling
attention to in a way in a very artistic
way to the plight of guest workers would
be another very different example and
then someone like Alexander a Sasha
skied on writes language poetry that's
extraordinarily difficult and meticulous
I mean just very difficult even on the
language of level of language itself but
also on the philosophical material that
it draws from so there the connection to
poetry is most abstract and has to do
perhaps with the way that language
poetry can expose discourse and the the
violence the everyday violence we commit
and the the language that we use the
phrases that we repeat how popular do
you think the poetry is in Russia is are
they widely read mm-hmm no this is an
avant-garde and Avant Garde's are always
speaking to a more limited audience that
said I think several of the poets
katiyal whom have mentioned several
times also another poet a Tom honest
median are interested in reaching wider
audiences through recourse to music so
they both also participate in bands
protest rock in the case of key domains
native Romanus Lincoln has a techno
poetry project and I think these are
ways of trying to reach and in part
create a wider audience again of course
this is not a massive movement but it's
a movement or it's a it's a pocket worth
examining nonetheless so and why is it
important to examine this pocket of
poets and and in terms of the movement
and you know what they're contributing
to history basically mm-hmm
I think it's more important than ever in
today's political climate especially for
me what the stakes are are disturbing a
media portrayal of Russia as somehow
culturally monolithic or static or
predictable it's extraordinarily
important
to bring attention to the attention of
students the attention of readers the
attention of other academics the
attention of American poets to the fact
that there are minority Rhian groups who
completely disagree with everything that
is being shown in mainstream culture and
who are holding their own these poets
and their their artist and activist
friends are collaborating with
communicating with and standing with
their counterparts in Ukraine in Poland
and have a great deal more in common
with American language poets and
activists and then people might think do
these poets correspond what you each
other or meet with each other
is there any do they have any kind of
relationship or very much so this is
this is one of the ways that I've
delimited my project why I'm trying to
think of it again as a as a loose
constellation these poets all published
in the journal Tehran states which has
been the absolute heart of my project
but then they've also collaborated with
each other in readings sometimes staging
dramas and in a chat book series the
craft series and then with translations
and original texts in the free marxist
press they're constantly coming up with
new projects and working together so in
some cases you can even think of them
well as a close-knit Network group of
friends even a kind of family of sorts
and this gives the gives it an identity
okay very good so when when can we
expect the book I'm hoping to finish it
next year next year is a leave year for
me okay and I'm hoping that that after
that shortly after that it will be
complete
one event that will be associated with
with the project as they mentioned that
some of these poets are coming here
they're coming for a conference at Yale
in April called political violence and
militant aesthetics after socialism and
that's actually happening in the Whitney
Humanities Center and is partly
sponsored made possible by the Macmillan
Center so there will be poetry readings
an event at art
face down downtown New Haven with local
artists participating as well as they
yell carry exciting we'll have to look
for that then okay thank you so much for
being here with us for having me okay
for more information about Professor
bolshevik and her research please visit
our website at yale.edu slash McMillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the McMillan report
made possible through the funding from
the Whitney and Betty McMillan Center
for International and area studies at
Yale
you